Now, there's a fight in Congress
going on right now
over funding the government.
Republicans
are holding DACA hostage
until the Democrats agree to pay
for Trump's big, beautiful wall.
It's a real
Deal or No Deal situation,
which is not good.
The Apprentice
was a way better show.
But if the stingy
"phlegm-ocrats" won't fund it,
how are we going to finance
the wall?
Oh, Jordan, it doesn't matter.
Kobi Libii, everybody. Kobi.
(cheering and applause)
Explain yourself.
Jordan, we don't need
to worry ourselves
over funding
an actual, physical wall
because the wall is a metaphor.
I didn't see Dead Poets Society.
(chuckles) Jordan,
a metaphor is a symbol,
and this symbol is very clear.
It says immigrants are... ugh.
And you can't quote me on that
in your mean think pieces
because it's just a noise.
So, it doesn't matter
who funds the actual wall
because this metaphorical wall
has already been built.
Okay, Kobi, look, I don't care
about your literary devices.
We need something solid
to keep the immigrants out.
Actually, we don't.
Most illegal immigrants are here
because they overstayed
their visas,
and the ones who cross
usually do so
at a border crossing.
A big concrete slab
won't help with any of that,
but a metaphorical wall will.
Oh, wrong!
Nothing is stronger than bricks,
a lesson I learn every week
in karate class.
But Jordan,
the metaphor is already
a huge success
at keeping people out.
We've created an environment
of animosity and unwelcomeness,
and we add another brick
to our metaphorical wall
every time we talk
about building a physical wall.
It gets higher
every time our president
calls other nations "shitholes"
and every time there's a story
about border patrol agents
destroying water supplies
left for migrants
so that they're stranded
in the desert
and forced to migrate
somewhere else--
heaven.
Wow.
Well, um, that-that's
a metaphor, right?
No, they really have done that.
But more importantly,
the culture
that inspired these guards
to deprive people
of life-giving water
is what's really working.
Under Trump,
there's been a 24% drop
in people caught illegally
crossing the U.S. border.
They're not even trying
to come now.
Wait, Kobi, look,
I-I still want a real wall,
the biggest, most beautiful wall
that Trump promised me.
Well, Jordan, people can always
get around a physical wall.
No, Trump's wall! No, not his!
No one can get past that.
Jordan, think about it.
Isn't there any way around it?
Okay. I guess you could maybe...
-build a really deep tunnel?
-And?
Well, I guess
you could pole vault over it.
Or dress up like a sexy lady
and hide a ladder
under your skirt,
seduce the border guard,
and while he's falling in love
with you, climb over.
Oh, yeah. Yeah, you could, uh...
you could get three guys,
stand on each other's shoulders,
the guy on top jumps over,
grabs the other guy's hands,
swings him over.
The third guy on the ground
probably doesn't get to go.
-Exactly. Yeah. -Yeah. Yeah.
You could, uh... I don't know.
You could tie a bunch
of balloons around your waist.
You could you get jetpacks
or ramps!
I forgot about ramps!
-What about ramps?
-Jordan, Jordan, it's fine.
It's okay
if Mexicans know about ramps
because America's true wall
is up here,
and there's no ramp
that can get over... ugh.
(shudders) Thank goodness.
Kobi Libii, everyone.